aujourd'hui je te donne un geste hyper
simple à faire pour ta santé ouvre tes
fenêtres voilà le jour même si tu as
cuisiné des oignons ou une raclette par
rapport à le lendemain si tu as manger
les oignons et tous les jours si bah il
y a pas de s en fait tous les jours il
faut le faire tous les jours et je vais
te donner deux très bonnes raisons
d'ouvrir tes fenêtres tous les jours
d'abord bah tu connais la pollution de
l'air extérieur mais il y a aussi la
pollution de l'air intérieur l'air il
est entre 5 et 10 fois plus pollué chez
toi que dehors les désodorés an les
produits d'entretien la fumée de ce que
tu cuisines ou des clopes il y a plein
de produits chimiques comme ça et je te
parle même pas des moisissures des
acariens et cetera tout ça c'est toxique
pour tes poumons ton cœur et ton cerveau
donc a au moins 10 minutes tous les
jours même s'il fait froid et ouais
parce que la deuxième bonne raison de le
faire c'est que non en faisant ça tu vas
faire sortir l'humidité de chez toi et
que l'air humide c'est plus difficile à
réchauffer aéré ça va te faire faire des
économies d'énergie allez fonce fais
gaffe quand même si tu habites en étage
je veux pas en